Hey everyone, Ryan here and welcome back to our orthodontic series.
So you may have noticed that we have a diagnosis and treatment planning video in most of our
series for the different topics of the clinical board exam.
And that's on purpose because it's really a staple in the health professions.
We figure out what the problem is, we plan out how to fix it, and then we do our best
to fix it.
And that's what diagnosis and treatment planning is all about.
In orthodontics though, it looks a little bit different.
So the full name of this specialty is orthodontics and dentofacial orthopedics.
So it's not only about straightening teeth, but also correcting malformations of the face.
So it really boils down to bare basics, broad spectrum, both the teeth and the face.
Dr. Profit, Dr. Ackerman, and Dr. Sarver are known for redefining what orthodontics
was all about in the context of the soft tissue paradigm.
So the objectives of orthodontic treatment under this paradigm can be viewed as macroesthetics,
a beautiful face, miniesthetics, a beautiful smile, and microesthetics zooming all the
way in for beautiful teeth.
Now, Dr. Ackerman and Dr. Profit went even further to represent five major characteristics
of an orthodontic patient via a Venn diagram.
So let's unpack what this is talking about.
When diagnosing a patient, we can place our findings into these five categories, facial
proportions and aesthetics, alignment and symmetry, transverse, anterior, which I'll
be referring to as AP for short and vertical.
Now I would normally go through each one of these in more detail one at a time, but it
was challenging putting this material together because there's so much overlap among these
five categories as you can see in the Venn diagram.
They are not clean cut categories, so instead keep these in the back of your mind and as
we go through the steps of an orthodontic exam, we'll fit things among one or more of
these categories.
So remember we said before that orthodontics is all about the teeth and the face, and so
if we really boil it down to the bare basics, our exam is focused on the teeth as part of
an intraoral exam and the face as part of an extra oral exam.
Then we also get some additional information from radiographs, particularly the cephalometric.
So let's go through each one of these one at a time.
So let's start with the teeth.
So malocclusion is a very broad term, it refers to a bad bite.
Malocclusion is not a disease, but a variation from what is considered ideal.
Now one of the most common factors of a malocclusion is some element of crowding.
The teeth being bunched up together like people in a crowd instead of straight along a nice
arc.
15% of adolescents and adults have severe crowding, much more than that are going to have some
degree of mild to moderate crowding, and then some percentage of the population has spacing.
And we talked in the last video about crowding being a math problem between two size and
arch size.
And we can think of it in the context of etiology that crowding carries a genetic predisposition.
There's some genetic predisposition to a discrepancy between two size and arch size.
For etiology specifics, malocclusion has an unknown cause in about 60% of cases.
The known cause is only in 5% of cases, and then that leaves 30% to 35% of the population
with a normal occlusion.
So if we move to the Edward-Angle molar classification, we have four main categories here.
So the first is normal class 1 occlusion, that's at 30% to 35% we saw in the last slide.
A normal class 1 occlusion in the angle classification means that the mesial buccal cusp of the maxillary
first molar occludes with the mesial buccal groove of the mandibular first molar, and
the teeth are aligned along this line of occlusion that goes for both the maxillary and the mandibular
arches.
For a class 1 maloclusion, which is the most common one up here, we have that same angle
class 1 molar relationship where that mesial buccal cusp occludes with the buccal groove
of the lower molar, but this time the teeth don't align along that line of occlusion
and there's some amount of crowding, or perhaps spacing, some misalignment, rotated teeth,
etc.
For a class 2 maloclusion, that means that the upper molar is too far forward and/or
the lower molar is too far back.
Another way to think about it is that the maxillary arch is displaced measly or anteriorly.
The teeth may or may not be incorrectly aligned, even if they were perfectly straight and this
was the molar relationship, we would call it a class 2 occlusion.
Now we have subdivision 1 and subdivision 2 for the class 2 maloclusions.
And 1 means that the upper incisors are flared forward or proclined.
So these front teeth are either flared like this, they're proclined out, and we usually
have some element of excess over a jet, we'll talk more about that in the next slide.
Subdivision 2 is where the upper incisors are more upright, more like they're pictured
in this image.
They're standing up a little bit straighter, they're retroclined, they're upright.
So in this case you may or may not have this excess over jet in the front, but you will
have some element of excess over bite.
In class 3 maloclusion, the upper molar is too far back and/or the lower molar is too
far forward.
Another way to think about this is that the maxillary arch is displaced posteriorly, again
like class 2, the teeth may or may not be incorrectly aligned.
This is the rarest form of maloclusion of these categories.
So now we can talk about incisor overlap, and I know I've thrown out these terms over jet
and over bite throughout the series, now we finally get to unpack what exactly these mean.
So over jet is defined as the horizontal overlap of incisors measured from the labial surface
of the lower incisor to the labial surface of the upper incisor.
So this image actually doesn't portray this accurately, the arrow should actually be going
all the way up here.
So normally the incisors, or I should say the upper incisors overlap the lower incisors
just by the thickness of their incisal edge.
So if the upper incisor is coupled with or butting up right against this lower incisor
as it should, they're contacting each other, the over jet should be about 2 to 3 millimeters,
which is just this amount, this thickness of the upper incisal edge.
So this image is of course depicting an excess over jet, class 2 incisors, particularly what
we would expect in a subdivision 1 malocclusion.
The opposite of that is called reverse over jet, where the lower incisors are actually
out in front of the upper incisors.
That would be a class 3 incisor relationship, excess is much more prevalent than reverse.
For overbite, that means the vertical overlap of the incisors, this is measured from incisal
edge to incisal edge.
So normally the lower incisors should again contact the lingual surface of the upper incisors
but it should be at or above the singular, so somewhere in this region.
This would create an overbite of about 1 to 2 millimeters.
So this image is showing somewhat of a deep bite, which means we have excess overbite.
The opposite of this is if we have some amount of vertical space between the upper and lower
incisal edges, which is called open bite.
Deep bite is much more prevalent than open bite.
Next we have cross bites.
So the first is anterior cross bite, and this refers to the maxillary anterior teeth being
lingual to the mandibular anterior teeth.
So actually another way to refer to this is reverse over jet, just like we talked about
in the last slide, where those lower incisors are out in front of the upper incisors.
Poster cross bite is a little bit more complex.
This refers to some mismatch in horizontal overlap of the back teeth.
So we know that the upper teeth should sit just outside the bottom teeth, overlapping,
kind of like a lid on a box.
So if we're looking at the upper teeth, those upper molars are configured like this, and
the lower molars should be just inside so that the lingual cusps of the upper molars
are occluding in the central fossa of those lower molars.
Poster cross bite means that this is somehow messed up, and we'll look at those two situations
here.
So lingual posterior cross bite, which is the more typical example when we say posterior
cross bite, is when the maxillary posterior teeth are lingual to the mandibular teeth.
That's what we see in this example.
They're located too far lingual relative to where those mandibular teeth are.
So they still interlock, but they're in the wrong configuration.
The other example of posterior cross bite, which is less common, is buckle posterior
cross bite.
And that's where the maxillary posterior teeth are buckle to the mandibular teeth.
And that's what we see in this example.
So they're completely buckle.
This is sometimes called a brody or a scissor bite where those upper teeth sit fully outside
the lower teeth, and it can be really disrupt normal function with chewing specifically.
So let's talk a little bit about the Bolton analysis.
So this measures tooth size discrepancy by comparing the upper and the lower teeth.
So there are accepted ratios between how wide the top teeth and how wide the bottom teeth
should be relative to each other, in order to get them to fit together properly, again,
to be the upper lid that fits snugly on the lower box.
So we can have two mismatches here.
The teeth can either be too large, and that's usually on the lower arch where teeth are
either the incisors, maybe some premolars, somewhere that teeth are just generally a little
bit too large, and they may require interproximal reduction or IPR.
So this refers to slenderizing the teeth, just a fraction of a millimeter between the
proximal contacts with a strip to gain some miniscule but important amount of space.
Again, that's usually done on the lower incisors.
The teeth can also be too small, and they may require build-ups.
These could be in composite, veneers or crowns.
And the most common example of this are peg laterals.
They don't even have to be quite this small, but they can be just slightly smaller than
normal, and your bulletin analysis where you measure all the mesiodistal widths and compare
them with one another, could reveal that you have small upper lateral incisors, smaller
premolars, and you may want to consider build-ups to fit together properly.
So next, let's talk about the facial exam.
So the face is really interesting.
There are some proportions that we expect in a "ideal configuration."
So we can break the face up into vertical thirds, three roughly equal regions.
The upper third goes from the hairline to the glabella, which is the most prominent part
of the forehead.
The middle third is from glabella to subnasality, which is the point just below the base of
the nose, and the lower third goes from subnasality to menton, which is the bottom of the chin.
Now the measurement of the upper face can often be difficult due to variability in the
hairline, but the good news is we can't change this dimension as orthodontist anyway, so that's
probably the least important of the three.
The most important is, of course, this lower third, asymmetrical growth of the mandible,
will show in the lower third, and this is where we have the most influence.
Ideally, in this lower third, the upper lip area composes the upper third of that lower
third, and the lower lip and chin compose the lower two thirds of that lower facial third.
So we can even break that one further into smaller thirds.
In a horizontal dimension, we can break the face into transverse fifths, so five roughly
equal regions, and this is when it gets really cool.
So the middle fifth goes from inner campus to inner campus.
Campus means corner of the eye.
The medial two fifths go from inner campus to outer campus, so for her right and the left,
then the outer two fifths go from outer campus to the lateral helix of the ear, that outer
most portion of the ear, and then the vertical line from the inner campus point should be
coincident with the outer base, so that's the sides of the nose.
So that line should be coincident with the sides of the nose, which it is in this case,
and not only that, but the vertical line from the outer campus should be coincident with
the gonial angles of the mandible, that part of the corner of the jawline there.
And then the mid-pupillary distance, this is from pupil to pupil, should be the same
distance and perfectly correlated with the commissures or the corners of the mouth.
So if we were to draw lines down from there, they would be coincident with the corners
of the mouth.
So a cool way to remember these transverse fifths is going from right to left, we have
an ear, an eye, the nose, an eye, an ear.
So if you remember an ear, eye, nose, eye, ear, you can probably piece together what
all those fifths are in relationship to each other and to the locations of the face.
So pretty cool, breaking down the face into thirds and fifths.
So next let's talk a little bit about skeletal classification.
So we talked about molar classification, we talked about how the incisors can be related
to each other.
Those were dental classifications.
Now we're talking about skeletal classification and skeletal malclusions, how the jaws are
related to each other.
So in class one, skeletal occlusion, we're talking about the jaws being well related
to n vertical.
This is a vertical line dropped down from nazion, which we'll talk about later in the
video when we get to cephalometrics.
For now, this n vertical line is shown by this vertical red line out in front.
So whereas dental classification has to do with the anterior posterior relationship of
upper teeth to lower teeth, usually for smaller.
Clinical classification has to do with anterior relationship of the upper jaw to the lower
jaw.
So in class two, skeletal mal occlusion, we have a prognathic or pertrusive maxilla, where
the maxilla sticks out too far.
Or we have a retronathic or retrusive mandible, where that is too far back from the n vertical
line, or we can have a combination of both.
I included these two terms because retronathic, retrusive, and prognathic, protrusive are
sometimes used interchangeably, and they're basically synonymous.
For class three, we have the opposite problems.
We have either a prognathic mandible, or a retronathic, or retrusive maxilla, or some
combination of both.
These are not exact numbers here, but class two, generally, we have about 10% of people
who have a pertrusive maxilla.
About 85% have this retronathic mandible, that's the most common problem that leaves
about 5% that have a combination of both.
And for class three, we have this is 60% for retrusive maxilla, that's the most common.
And then for prognathic mandible, that's about 20% of those patients, and then that leaves
about 20% that have a combination of both.
Again, those numbers are not too too important for the board exam.
What's probably most important here is that the retrusive elements are the most common
for both of those malocclusions.
All right, so we can continue to look from the profile view, this time looking more
at soft tissues.
So this is all about facial convexity.
We're looking at the facial plane formed by glabella, to subnase alley, to soft tissue
pagonion, which is the chin point, the most anterior portion of the chin in soft tissue.
I believe I touched on these before, but just to confirm, glabella is the area of the forehead.
That's typically most prominent, it's between the eyebrows, and the subnase alley is the
base of the nose.
So for the facial convexity, we're basically drawing line segments from these three points
and seeing how straight of a line that would be.
So for a straight profile, those line segments between glabella, base of nose, and chin point
are going to basically form a straight line.
You can see a straight line here, and the subnase alley is a little bit in front of that, but
that's hardly a few degrees off of that straight line.
So anything that's generally under 10 degrees of a slight inclination, we're going to call
a straight profile.
That's usually coincident with a class one occlusion, skeletal, and dental occlusions.
So a convex profile is where these line segments would form a convex curve.
Maybe the subnase alley is way out here, and/or maybe the chin points way back there.
And of course, it doesn't have to be that severe, but anything that's a little bit more
than a 10 degree inclination, we're going to call convex.
It's usually coincident with a class two maloclusion.
Then concave is where the line segments form, a concave curve.
So subnase alley might be back, chin point may be forward, something like that.
And that's usually coincident with a class three occlusion.
So facial divergence is rarely tested, but sometimes it does come up.
It's similar to facial convexity, but it is slightly different.
So I want to go over that discrepancy.
So facial divergence refers to inclination of the lower face relative to where the forehead
is.
So a straight or no facial divergence or straight divergence, I guess you could say, is very
similar to what we just talked about with facial convexity.
This is you're going to drop a vertical line down from glabella and subnase alley and chin
point are very close to that line.
Posterior divergent means that the entire line dropped down from the forehead to the
chin goes posteriorly.
So subnase alley is a little bit more posterior and chin points even more posterior.
Interior divergent means we drop that same line down, but this time subnase alley is
a little bit more forward and chin points even more forward.
So it's not quite the same as convexity.
This is talking about everything is kind of moving posteriorly when we go up to down.
Everything is moving anteriorly as we go from up to down.
Now the nice part about this is that this does usually fit with a class two maloclusion,
as you could see, and this would usually coincide with a class three maloclusion.
Now we can zoom in a little bit more on profile and talk about specific angles that are formed
in the soft tissue.
So the nasolabial angle is formed between the columnella of the nose, that's this bottom
part of the nose here that separates the two nostrils and the philtrum.
That's that vertical indentation of the upper lip.
And that makes sense.
This is nasophore nose and labial for lip.
So this angle should be approximately 90 degrees.
It's determined by a bunch of different things, AP position of the maxilla, AP position of
the upper incisors, and particularly vertical position of the nasal tip, like if the nose
is upturned in a younger child, that can make this nasolabial angle a lot larger.
But there's quite a bit of range that is perfectly acceptable here.
The thickness of the upper lip could also contribute to nasolabial angle.
Going down, mentolabial angle is between the lower lip and the chin.
So mento for chin, labial for lip.
This should be around 120 degrees.
This one's affected by lower incisor position and vertical height of the lower facial third.
It's sometimes also called a mentolabial fold or mentolabial sulcus.
And lastly we have the cervicomental angle.
This one goes from menton, which is base of the chin again, to our point, or reflex point,
as a depth of the throat, and then to the base of the neck.
This one again, well this one has a pretty large range.
It goes from 90 degrees to up to 120 degrees.
Other considerations of this one are gender, soft tissue sag from aging and body weight.
Alright so lips are arguably, if we're talking about the soft tissue paradigm, the most important
soft tissue consideration of a modern orthodontist, outside of the gingiva and the peridontal tissues.
So how I remember the lips are the three P's, that's position, posture and proportions.
So for lip position, we draw a line that's tangent to the nose and the chin.
So this line right here, tangent to both of those two points, is called rickett line,
or aesthetic line.
So the lower lip should be on this line and the upper lip should be slightly behind the
line.
If both of your lips are ahead of the line, they're considered prominent or protrusive.
If they're behind the line, they're considered retrusive.
So that's a quick and dirty way of judging AP position of the lips.
Note that this is not very useful if the nose and/or chin are excessively large.
This is most useful for patients in their adolescent ears.
So for lip posture, our second P, we're looking for lip competence at rest.
So we have three to four millimeters of separation at rest, which we see here, and mantelis strain
on closure.
So this means that in order for them to get a lip seal, they would have to strain their
mantelis muscle, so we can see all erased the drawing, so you can appreciate that amount
of muscle strain of the mantelis.
So the muscles have to tighten up to get the lips to seal over the teeth.
So the combination of separation at rest and having to strain that mantelis to get the
lips to close is lip incompetence.
Lip competence means that the lips can form a seal over the teeth at rest without any
amount of strain.
For lip proportions, we're simply looking at their dimension.
Are they thick and full, or are they thin and flat?
How much vermilion, the actual lip tissue, do they display?
So this one considers kind of all three planes of space.
There's an AP component, a vertical component, and probably even a transverse component.
For posture, this is pretty much a vertical issue.
For position, it's pretty much an AP issue.
So those are the three P's of the lips.
Incisor display refers to how much of the incisors show, either at rest or on smile.
So incisor display at rest, we're looking for about two to four millimeters being aesthetically
pleasing.
So this is a little bit of the incisor showing.
Again, if you're at rest, maybe your lips are touching, you have lip seal, that's acceptable
as well.
On smile, we want all of the upper incisors to show with about one to two millimeters
of gingiva above them.
So that's not including the papilla area, we want some little bit amount of gingiva showing
above those teeth, that's a youthful look.
Any more than two millimeters is considered a gummy smile by the lay person.
About 75% of the incisors showing on smile is considered the minimum acceptable amount.
And finally, buckle quarters.
So this refers to the dark space between the maxillary posterior teeth and the corner of
the mouth upon smile.
So that's this amount of negative space.
Sometimes it's referred to if you have a collapsed narrow arch form, it can result in a lot of
shadowing negative space referred to as wide buckle quarters.
Having treatment that involves lateral expansion of the premolars and molars into this space
can improve the transverse smile dimension and create a more medium or even narrow buckle
quarters if there is minimal dark space in those corners of the mouth.
So a broad arch will result in narrow buckle quarters while a narrow arch will result in
wide buckle quarters.
And the last part we'll talk about are cephalometrics, which look at both the teeth and the face
in a very unique perspective.
So the lateral cephalometric gives us a lot of information about a patient's heart tissue
as well as soft tissue structures from the profile view.
So I've marked a bunch of cephalometric landmarks here that we can go over together.
So our first one we'll talk about is this one back here.
It's not very commonly used but it's called the Bolton Point and that's BO for short.
It's the highest point in the upward curvature of the occipital bone around the center of
this gigantic frame and magnum where the spinal cord runs from the brain down here.
Next we have the Bayesion, which is this point right here, that's BA for short.
And the Bayesion is the lowest point of the anterior margin of the foramen magnum and it
points towards the dens or the odontoid process which is right here of c2, that's the axis
of the vertebrae.
We'll talk a little bit more about vertebrae in a little bit.
The next point is the Articulari ar for short and that's right here, that's the intersection
between the zygomatic arch which is running here and the posterior border of the ramus.
Note that there's actually, you can see both Ramai, you can see one here and then one further
back here and this means that the patient was either there's some degree of asymmetry
between the right and left sides or probably more possible.
The patient wasn't positioned properly in the imaging unit.
So in that case we just split the difference between the left and right sides and we pick
in the middle of those two projections.
Next point is the Purion which is up here, PO for short and that's the highest point
of the external auditory meatus, that's the outer ear opening and this part is the ear
rod of the cephalometric machine.
So we would imagine that's pretty close to Purion which is the outer ear hole in the skull.
So next let's go to this one, that's Condillion CO and it's the most posterior and superior
point on the outline of the condler head.
The condyle can be pretty tough to see in a cephalometric.
Next we'll go over here, this is the Terego maxillary fissure PTM and that's the base
of this fissure, it's often a teardrop shape that runs along the back of the maxilla.
A bunch of vessels and nerves run in and out of that fissure.
Next we'll go up here, this is Cella S for short, it's the midpoint of the Cella Terseca
which is the saddle in which the pituitary gland lives.
This point over here is Orbitale, that's the lowest point on the inferior margin of the
orbit where the eye lives.
Up here is Nazion or N and that's the anterior point on the intersection between the nasal
bone down here and the frontal bone up here.
You can almost appreciate the little suture running here between those two bones which
is pretty cool.
Alright next let's go here, this point is the anterior nasal spine and that's the sharp
projection of the maxilla anteriorly and then we have the posterior nasal spine which is
usually right below the PTM and that's the sharp projection of the palatine bones posteriorly.
That's where that hard palate ends.
Right here we have A point and that's the innermost portion, innermost point on the contour of
the maxilla, that's the innermost point on the contour of the maxillary bone.
Likewise we have the B point which again is the innermost point on the contour of the
mandibular bone.
Down here we have three right up next to each other, this one is Pagonion, that's the most
anterior point of the chin, you may remember we had a soft tissue Pagonion which is the
soft tissue counterpoint to this hard tissue landmark.
Down here we have menton which is ME for short, that's the most inferior point on the chin,
again we have the soft tissue menton which we talked about before when we were talking
about facial thirds and other things and the point between Pagonion and menton is called
Nafion and GN are the letters there.
Gonian is back here, that's G-O, that's the midpoint on the contour connecting the Ramis
and the body of the mandible and I believe that's all the points we have here.
Other structures to point out we have the frontal sinus up here, the ethmoid air cells,
we have the maxillary sinus this gigantic thing here, the sphenoid sinus, the mastoid
air cells, here is C1 which is the atlas, C2 with the dens running up here, that's the
axis, we have C3, C4 and we can keep going down, this is the hyoid bone right in here,
the epiglottis here and of course we can appreciate the soft tissue profile with the nose, the
lips and the chin, so lots of stuff to get from a cephalometric x-ray and some really
cool stuff there, here's a summary of everything that we just talked about, so from those points
we can gather some important information like reference planes that connect two of those
points together, for example we could connect cella and nazion and get the SN plane which
represents the anterior cranial base, if we connect poorion and orbitally we get what's
called the frankfort horizontal plane, which is an incredibly important reference plane,
if we connect ANS and PNS we get the palatal plane, if we connect lower six which is the
cusp tip of the lower first molar and lower one, the incisal edge of the lower incisor,
we get a occlusal plane and if we connect gonion and nafion we get the mandibular plane
which is another really, really important reference plane, the sussuni analysis states
that all five of these reference planes should intersect at around the back of the head,
the occiput of the head, if they intersect earlier the patient is considered hyperdivergent,
if they intersect later they're considered hypo-divergent, just one example of how these
reference planes can be used diagnostically, so probably the most important use of the
cephalometric is a cephalometric analysis, this is used to evaluate the relationship
of the jaws and the dental units to each other, this used to be done on acetate paper, but
today we use computer software and mark all of those landmarks we just went over and
in the software would develop a tracing from which you can gather all these linear and
angular measurements, these measurements allow you to evaluate the relationship of the jaws
and the teeth to each other and the cranial base, to which everything is attached, and
you would compare your patient to numerical norms for their age, racial, and ethnic groups,
so sna is a very common angular measurement, this is the angle from cella to nazion to
a point, and it represents the relationship of the maxilla to the cranial base, a bigger
angle means that the maxilla is further forward, a smaller angle means that the maxilla is
further back, snb, cella to nazion to b point refers to the relationship of the mandible
to the cranial base, a bigger angle means the mandibles more forward, smaller angle means
the mandibles further back, and then a and b kind of combines those two together, and
this instead looks at the relationship of the maxilla to the mandible, and this is the one
that comes up on the board exam quite frequently, so we go from a point to nazion to b point,
and this angle is very, very small, if we're at around zero degrees, or below, we're in
the negatives, that is considered a class three skeletal malocclusion, is again, we're talking
about the jaw units, we're not looking specifically at what the teeth are doing, so zero or below
class three, around two degrees is considered normal, four degrees or above is considered
class two, so this is what will most likely come up on the board exam, they'll give you
an angle, and if it's zero or below class three, four or above class two, and if it's
somewhere between zero and four, that's a normal class one skeletal relationship, and
the last diagnostic thing we can do with cephalometrics is to superimpose them, so we superimpose
or overlap cephalometric tracings from different time points on top of each other to see what
has changed, so this could be to evaluate growth changes over time, or to see what the effects
of treatment were, either orthodontics or orthonathic surgery. All right, so that's
it for this video, thank you so much for watching everyone, I know it was a long one, but there's
a lot of good information in there, and I wanted to make sure we included all of it,
so please like this video if you enjoyed it, and subscribe to this channel for much more
on dentistry, if you're interested in supporting this channel and what I do, please check out
my Patreon page, thank you to all of my patrons for all of their support, you can unlock extras
like access to my video slides to take notes on, and practice questions for the board exams,
so go check that out, the link is in the description, thanks again for watching everyone, I'll see
you in the next video.